guess what marble fans tickets are on
sale right now for Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. ah Guardians
you ready for one last ride your
favorite group of Misfit heroes are back
as they defend the Galaxy one last time
the stakes
big the action
big and Groot
also big he left out some important
information but
that is the gist of it get your tickets
now for Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
only in theaters May 5th
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel Studios has officially
released new footage for Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 because today tickets
have officially gone on sale for
Guardians 3. if you are trying to see
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 on opening
day the very first viewing I suggest
going to get your tickets now now on top
of them releasing some new footage for
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. James
Gunn has also released the official
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 soundtrack
on Spotify and there are 17 songs on it
that you can listen to right now and to
top it all off we have seven new posters
for Guardians of the Galaxy and out of
the seven of them six of them arguably
seven of them are all focused on rocket
with some of the posters only being
rocket now James Gunn has come out and
confirmed that rocket has always been
the protagonist of the Guardians of the
Galaxy films now of course Star-Lord is
in Gamora nebula the whole entire team
of course are the protagonists but James
Gunn even said himself that in that
moment in time where he was no longer
attached to direct or right the
Guardians of the Galaxy movies he was
super super sad because he wanted to
finish the story of Rocket Raccoon now
of course he ended up coming back he
wrote and directed Guardians volume 3
which is out next month and the story of
not only Rocket Raccoon is coming to an
end but the current Guardians of the
Galaxy team it's coming to an end as
well and even in this new footage that
we get we hear Star-Lord say alright
Guardians are you ready for one last
ride and even Zoe Saldana in the promo
says your favorite group of Misfit
heroes are back as they defend the
Galaxy one last time so this is it their
story is coming to an end and speaking
of the end first things first let's talk
about these posters like I mentioned we
have seven new posters and if you take a
look at them a lot of them are focused
on Rocket one of them shows rocket from
a little baby raccoon Brown up to what
he is now a raccoon that has been
experimented on and kind of enhanced by
the high evolutionary we have another
one that shows him in front of a
chalkboard on the chalkboard we see a
very long and complicated mathematical
equation at the top of it it says see it
in real 3D then if you notice at the
bottom of it it says Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 but below that it says I
didn't ask for any of this now this is a
direct callback to Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 1 where rocket is drunk and
he gets in a fight with Drax and he says
he thinks I'm some stupid thing well I
didn't ask to be mid he thinks I'm
stupid
turn into some
it's a little monster rocket no one's
calling you a monster
well rocket was made by the high
evolutionary the main villain of this
movie and now they are returning to him
or rocket gets captured and is brought
back to the high evolutionary because we
know that he escaped this in turn puts
his fellow Guardians of the Galaxy in
trouble in Jeopardy and we know that
some of the Guardians are going to die
most likely Drax in fact I'm thinking
Drax dies for sure maybe even some other
ones as well and a lot of people aren't
expecting rocket to die but since really
this movie is focusing on him and his
story coming to an end we really don't
know hopefully he gets his happy ending
and simply leaves but we don't know but
him saying I didn't ask for any of this
is because the high evolutionary is
after him again and now all of his
friends are in trouble and it sucks
because rocket was kidnapped as a baby
raccoon and experimented on something
that he never asked for and never wanted
but again this movie is heavily focused
on him if we continue down to the other
posters we can see Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 Feel It In 4dx he is right
there in the front right next to Cosmo
then we have another poster where
literally all of the other Guardians are
cut off we just see their feet and we
see a full Rocket Raccoon up front we do
see Cosmo in the back but rocket is
right up there up front and the last one
released is literally a close-up of
Rocket's face we see his nose and his
eye and in his eye we can see the rest
of the Guardians of the Galaxy is new
and true family it's true he didn't ask
to be made he didn't ask to be
experimented on by the high evolutionary
but he didn't ask for a family either
but that is what he got he got people he
could count on and people that love him
and he loves back make no mistake this
is going to be a very emotional movie
and if rocket dies I think a lot of
people are gonna lose it now if you
haven't caught the new spot that Marvel
released today and a couple of days ago
as well for tickets going on sale check
out the new footage wait
wait
go go
I was eight years old when I left her
you want me to drive no I'll drive
figure out how to put it in backwards
Galaxy Vol 380 PG-13 tickets on sale
Monday now what's interesting about this
is of course they're saying wait because
tickets are about to go on sale so wait
for the tickets to go on sale but this
is an actual scene from the movie of
course and what's interesting about this
is as we see star-lords say wait we see
him look out the window to his right and
if you look closely out the window you
can see a ship pull up next to them so
what's most likely Happening Here is
that the Guardians are being hunted down
for whatever reason because there are a
few reasons that they would be hunted
down one is that Aisha and The Sovereign
are looking for him we know that Aisha
wants to destroy the Guardians of the
Galaxy that's why she has created Adam
Warlock and we know she'll be hunting
them down however she'll most likely
just send Adam Warlock to hunt them down
as we have seen in the trailers however
they have said that Adam Warlock is
basically kind of like a baby like a
child he's a newborn and doesn't
understand everything yet so it is
possible that Sovereign does send ships
as well with Adam Warlock or it could
simply be the high evolutionaries people
we know that he wants backrocket raccoon
we know that they take Rocket Raccoon
based off of everything we know about
this movie already and that the
Guardians have to go and retrieve him
and rescue him so any of these reasons
are most likely why these people are
coming up to the Guardians of the Galaxy
and they're about to book it out of
there we also have new footage of Gamora
fly in the Guardians of the Galaxy's new
ship now we know that she doesn't start
off with the Guardians of the Galaxy but
eventually they do meet up and they join
together for a common cause most likely
to take out the high evolutionary
because keep in mind Gamora even in the
other timeline that she came from
probably knows about the high
evolutionary and perhaps she has
actually wanted to take him out before
that could be why they are coming
together because we've seen enough of
the trailer footage to know that the
Guardians aren't necessarily getting
along with this Gamora she hasn't really
had any of the experiences that made the
other Gamora who she was and since
Gamora and Adam Warlock have a romance
in the comics I'm actually kind of
expecting nothing to really happen
between Star-Lord and Gamora here in in
fact Gamora might even be one of the
characters who dies she is time
displaced this family that she has now
isn't really a family to her but I'm
assuming by the end of it she kind of
connects with at least nebula and
perhaps sacrifices herself to save some
of the other Guardians now of course to
top it all off we have a scene on
counter Earth as they call it in the
comics this was a planet that the high
evolutionary took him and his subjects
the animal humanoid experiments that he
essentially evolved and made into humans
they left Earth and came to a new planet
and called it counter Earth and his goal
was to make it exactly like Earth which
is why in this scene Star-Lord is
driving a car no they are not on Earth
they are on counter earth like I said
the high evolutionary made his Planet
exactly like Earth this is why it looks
like a suburb but if you take a look at
the people they are still animals and
Star-Lord can't drive a car he never
learned how to drive a car he
understands the basic concept but as he
explains to nebula he left earth when he
was eight so he has no idea how to drive
an actual car turning the windshield
wipers on when he's trying to go into
reverse overall this movie still looks
amazing and it's James Gunn still at the
helm so I'm sure that his final
Guardians of the Galaxy film won't be
anything but amazing but go ahead and
let us know your thoughts about all of
this new footage and the new posters in
the comments down below what do you
think who's gonna die in this film leave
your comments in the comment section
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe stay up to date on the latest
MCU and DC news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof